نحن الان في بدايات التنميه في اخي الكريم
في بدايات التنوير وهكذا تقول ما قبل
التنميه يرجع عليه لا نزال في بدايه
البدايات لانه التنوير الديني قصه كبيره
قصه ضخمه جدا تعني غرب التراس كله من اوله
لاخره وهذا الشيء
يصعب ان يفعله المثقفون العرب في بلدانهم
لذلك يهاجرون الى جامعه الغرب
بامريكا بالشجره
امريكا
بس على هايله جدا يعني كيف يمكن ان نفشر
تراسنا
اتجاه التنميه والتحرير ضد اتجاه التكسير
والتحريم ولا
والاقتصاد الاخرين هذه قصه ضخمه جدا لانه
همم نحن مشبعون بعقليه القرون الوسطى عندك
عقليه القرون الوسطه عندك عقليه العصور
الحديثه
مش نفس الشيء في العصور الوسطى كانوا
يعتقدون في العصور انه لا يمكن ان يوجد
الا دين واحد صحيح على وجه الارض وداخل
هذا الدين لا يمكن ان يوجد الا مذهب واحد
صحيح على وجه الارض الان ما عاد فينا نعيش
هيك لانه هذا يعني
الكنيسه المسيحي كانت تكثر كل الاديان
الاخرى
الاسلام تكثر
الصوتيين
هذا المنطق القرار هذا مفهوم الخروج هذا
لا يمكن ان يستمر
20 ما الذي يمكن ان يتحرك
يعني اسالك بصيغه اخرى انت اليوم تتابع
ربما يحدث والتغيرات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على كل المستويات الاجتماعيه
ثقافيه الفكريه وغيرها من الامور الى اي
متى هذا التحرك او هذا التغيير هو مؤثر في
العالم العربي في دول الجوار في ربما
التعامل مع هذه القضايا القضايا التطرف
الارهاب ومساله التنوير الديني
طبعا طبعا ما يحصل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ينعكس على ينعكس على العالم كله
ههه لانه المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني
الحرمين الشريفين مكه والمدينه يعني قدس
الاقداس الاسلاميه موجوده فيها وبالتالي
اذا اتجهت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
باتجاه التنوير
والتفكير العقلاني والفلسفي سوف ينعكس
علينا جميعا على ذلك كل الدول العالم
العربي والاسلامي لذلك انا اشد وثيقه مكه
المكرمه
والحقيقه همم ينبغي الاعتراف انه القائد
محمد بن سلمان في السعوديه يقوم بعمل
ممتاز جدا ممتاز وعمل همم سوف يفيد الجميع
وكذلك يفعل الشيخ محمد بن زايد في
الامارات العربيه
العرب من عقليه القرون الوسطى من عقليه
الانغلاق من عقليه اقصاء الاخرين ونبذهم
واحتقالهم والجراء اديانهم ده نستطيع ان
نعيش في قناه لا نستطيع ان نستمر في
الجراء الاديان الاخرى ابدا الاعتراف
بالاديان الاخرى اليهوديه المسيحيه
البوزيه الهندوسيه
الصينيه ينبغي ان نحترم دراسات البشريه
الاخرى لعاد لكي همم نستطيع ان نحن نعيش
فقط
فالقرن العاشر على
والاقصائي للاخرين وهمم نابذه للاخرين
وايضا من الزراعه الاديان لا ينبغي ان
نشتري التراسات الدينيه الاخرى لانها ليست
ليست من تراثنا لا ينبغي هذا
احترام كل التراسات الدينيه للبشريه